they're on their feet here at the
Capitol One Arena Berton stabile five
seconds Spiel crossover in the paint
step back for the win got it
tens of a second remaining
credit the Bulls doing a good job not
letting Brad get it on the first round
but great job by Brad on the step back
to focus locking in that window
having enough time and patience
complete the game towards the rim all
you need is a two
oh he's on Brown Jr finding bio bio puts
it up and in and the Wizards Take the
Lead there is still time on the clock
how about the fine from Troy Brown Jr
the cut by Beale in the Stream by Moe
Wagner and the pass and hold on Coach
Brooks great play great play
quickly to wall
all measures
deal gets open for three dagger
the Spurs at Verizon center
Bradley Beal stroke is perfect sir
we do it all the way good Baseline fake
gets Aldridge out of the pitcher he has
a clear look
they go to Beale to try to win it
Bradley Beal he's got a look Waits
shoots off balance
now Brad takes us all the way to the
basket he can get some contact
here's veal seeing a lot of active hands
and he goes off last and he gets it to
go Bradley Beal with his 19th points and
he is pumped
wall puts it in the hands of field
[Applause]
peel on the drive goes to the basket
lays it in
It's Bradley Beal drives to the basket
14 of his 21 points
[Music]
[Applause]
they floated to the rim and it's good
score of the basket
you've got to be kidding me
how about that looking for Beale deal
back to Westbrook for three in the tie
it's short chase down by Beale in the
corner for three and his that's it a
chance for the Wizards to go up by one
look at this
deal is the one who got it himself
wow Brad chasing that down
deal steps back for three headset
Bradley Beal hits it and we are tied at
121.
what a shot by Beale for Washington an
incredible play all of Taj Gibson's
momentum is going towards the basket
Wizards need a three to tie wall had it
now he'll take the shot give it up to
beef Bill's three-pointer good Bradley
Beal ties in a selfless play by John
Wall he could have taken the three Mr
Beale 25 points for Beale five of seven
from long range 10 of 22 overall on the
night point three they gotta go quick
Beale will pull up for three he hit six
[Applause]
ties the game at 113 with 2.4 seconds to
play
Otto for three
field for three
you've got Bradley beer with his sixth
three-pointer ties the game at 124. 40
points offensive rebound and a
fortuitous tip right to him
gets gets the ball back
[Applause]
deal gets free puts it up score of the
field goal he'll go to the line
hey Brad Stevens will continue to do
that uh if it's a three-point margin
Bill gets the rebound puts it up and in
and the game is tied at 113.
perfect bounce back
and the Red Sea Parts it Parks right for
him for the layup it's down low for
Marquis Morris more there he beat him
last time kicks it out to be over
Trayvon Johnson and a great Champion
side Bradley Beal are you send fans home
Kevin this is how you close the arena
down if you're the opposing team you can
take it down the lane late in the game
you dunk on everybody and you look at
the crowd and said I hope you enjoyed my
time at this Arena
deal gets doubled Westbrook
[Applause]
feel here we lost the dribble got it
back the reverse with the left oh
Bradley Beal
look at it
[Music]
gotta want got away with one on that one
good job getting over the top of that
screen there's Thomas Brown comes back
for the big block and right there JK you
showed your hand
again can the Wizards get over the hump
right here at attack going downhill
against a bonus right now there it is
with the left he puts it in 50 for Beale
and the lead for the Wizards still
gaffer coming up setting this pick and
catching sabonis downhill reaching gotta
remember to play before that they were
trying to double team and trap him in
those picks and rui was rewarded
[Applause]
lead
that ties his season High
field drives Lay It reverse and a foul
but you don't have the feet to keep up
with me his creative use of the window
too
they get that ball movement feel
jump stop hangs puts it in tied up at
109.
Beale trying to get free
and now Beale goes to the hoop and he's
got it and the foul
man Brad going downhill is Unstoppable
once he gets two steps ahead of you
it's all she wrote
we're going one on one on deshante Deal
inside the three-point line it hits
nothing but net
eight seconds on the shot clock
just feel now trying to get downhill
step back step through and go
up just like the play against Chicago in
the home opener Bradley Beal now putting
Washington up
[Applause]
[Music]
in the Twin Cities
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
clutch bucket at the free-throw line
pretty good defense by Christy but
better offense by Brad and then